in a poll conducted by Redfield and
Wilton strategies for Newsweek 18% of
Voters say they're more likely or
significantly more likely to vote for a
candidate endorsed by Taylor Swift a
restaurant isn't going to take a poll of
the public every month and then decide
on what its menu is going to be based on
what a majority of people say they want
looks like meat's back on the menu boy
you don't want a meal that's decided
much less prepared based on a democratic
vote if you value your country and the
future of your nation that you are
living in and that your family and your
children live in you can't just allow
that and the only argument for it is
yeah but it's what they want